I was pretty much afraid of everything
afraid of the world afraid of speaking
if you know really really shy kid so
yeah we went to a place that no one
spoke English or people were telling us
you know I learned English from your
lyrics like oh hello he's Asian
my name is fr Michael my one wouldn't
believe I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today I'm going to learn from the
co-founder and main songwriter for
Metallica James Hetfield I think on its
top ten schools rule number ten is my
personal favorite and I love to know
which ones you guys like best and as
always guys are watching issue something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below the folks
around to others who can be inspired I'm
going to cry as well and else when you
write it down as much more likely to
stick to yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
ah
I was pretty much afraid of everything
afraid of the world afraid of speaking
you know really really shy kid music was
a way to speak as simple as that
I could either just journal write poetry
write just whatever was in my head and
sit down to determine a few chords and
put that together and that's me that's
me telling the world about me when I
can't do it on my own
so music was the voice I didn't have I
wanted to talk to you about like there's
a transition that very successful people
make and either they make it or they
don't and the the transition is to go
from being hungry and filled with all
this angst to being like stupid wealthy
and famous but still keeping your art
relevant like how do you do that ah
we're super competitive people were
really perfectionists and we hate to let
each other down there's a there's always
a better riff coming there's always a
better album maybe there's the never
satisfied part to us that will keep us
going till we die you know there's
always the ultimate lyric that's going
to connect to everyone in the world or
something there is always a better
something that we haven't got yet how do
you stay grounded how do you do it well
I've got a get a wife that kicks my
first of all kids that tell it like it
is G Hill that to me is love right there
when you're kids you know dad you're
being a jerk you know I love that that
that's what helps me a lot
family certainly does that I think the
guys in the band too we all keep each
other in check like it you know dude is
that limo a little too long come on I
mean you know just goofy things like
that you know we try and keep each other
real so I think not surrounding
ourselves with yes men too which can
really just totally distort your reality
most things in life that
worthwhile you got to work at you got to
work at you get out what you put in as
simple as that that's a kind of a
universal law so yeah it's not pick up
the guitar and go haha which I've done
he's a home front of the mirror lots you
know hey I'm really good and you got to
have that attitude too but it does take
work it does take you know some
dedication you know but if you love
doing it it's not as hard as is it is it
could be if you're you know you're doing
something that's not it you're not as
interested in how many people have a
dream when they're kids of being a rock
star how many people get to be in
Metallica it's crazy dude wake up every
day and think I'm freaking blessed I
mean this is unbelievable what if I
complain once today punch me in the face
you know this is stupid
you know exactly stupid and that I would
complain about something but I tell you
it is hard at times being on the road
doing stuff and when you don't want to
do stuff you do it but then you find
something you find someone you find a
thing and it's usually someone in the
crowd that's just you know I see myself
right there it's like I'm that kid right
there at the Motorhead concert looking
up at let me go on business Picasa and
so I just suck that energy and go all
right this is a this is all I need this
is all I need right now what are you
most credit with the success we ongoing
the continued success in Metallica look
what there's one thing that is really
the core of that honesty for sure
honesty whether it's in a some kind of
monster movie or the music or a live
show being honest you know at the show
last night the one intro ends enter to
one I go out and I start playing fade to
black like what the hell and me
realizing and getting that wave of like
shame like oh my god
you're an idiot made like alright just
laugh at it cuz it's kind of funny and
what else are you going to do if you
know and then start this one song and
then later talk about it
so being honest about it is so freeing
being honest with each other with
ourselves
you know we're 53 what's it looked like
what are we going to do how long can we
tour you know what's going to you know
how can we stay healthy and happy you
know so being honest with each other I
think being on stage is a different hat
it's a different mindset it's a
different space
it's a to me time stops there's no pain
there's it's it's like you know when
when people artists talk about being in
the zone that is the zone I can get in
that zone even here just sitting playing
and forget you guys are here it somehow
the world goes away whether that's good
or bad it's difficult to come out of
sometimes but you know that's the curse
of it but the blessing is there is that
focus and there is that their sense of
purpose sense of being sense of
communication sense of creation there's
this like that's a reason that's a
reason I'm here there's times when I
haven't played for a couple weeks and my
wife will say god you're grumpy go play
guitar it's like oh yeah
now go on I'll play and then I feel
better now it's just it's just what it
is it's a part of me it's like I got to
have it you know it's it's my coffee in
the morning too and it's my my chill in
the evening you still get nervous before
you play show I'm nervous right now yes
thank you I'm you know I my theory is is
if you're not nervous then something
wrong because there's some intense stuff
about to happen and yeah there's a
little there's a there's always the
jitters before you go out and we have
our little we have our little huddle and
kind of calm each other down
you know say hey whatever happens is
supposed to happen so you know we try
not to take ourselves too seriously but
yeah we're nervous because the it's a
it's a big deal and it's a-you know it's
important every little thing that we've
done in our careers anything that's
maybe gotten our way or showed up on our
pathway we thought wow this is this is
great this is the coolest we've made it
you know
we're on tour we have a bus so we have a
record or we're on someone else's big
tour there's been so many great little
successes along the whole way and I'd
say after 36 years still loving and
caring for what we do and seeing the
great results from it it's a it's a more
than any dream that we could have dreamt
that's come true for us we played in
front of half a million people and half
a million people and where was that this
was in Russia
Klose an airfield oh my god so we've
done that what was that like it was a C
so you have Russian people that mean
that's what it was
cinge we the 90 91 91 91 when the you
know the curtain came down and all of
that and Time Warner had a they wanted
to basically get their foot in the door
and so they were created a free concert
it was it was ac/dc us Pantera and I
think maybe a local band or some other
bands I'm sorry if I can't remember but
they flew us in there we landed in this
airfield Oh Miley crew was on it
landed in this airfield and as far as
the eye could see it was a free concert
and it was just people and we get on
stage and do what we do but there were
it was military you know military and
the Sun just Christ look at that photo
holy Sh
holy Sh Jamie go full screen with that
just go with that one what enough oh my
god that's insane that it that the one
cool there might be something else but
it looks a little nervous it says here
is from 91 Moscow so Wow
yeah pretty remarkable and there were
dude imagine the sea of people like that
and see there's a helicopter helicopter
flying over people oh my god if that
thing goes down now they could be
chopping alcoho no leave I could go
right up there that one on stage facing
those people oh my god that is insane
that helicopter would come down close
and they were yelling at people like
stop you know people were moshing or
going crazy they didn't know what that
was
Oh oh wow no it was like a fight
I freaking caught me in this country man
waiting out of order this is chaos it
didn't have the internet then either no
way they didn't know what to expect of
that so there are deaf people throwing
you know hitting people from that from
the helicopter and down on the front
there there were guys in uniforms you
know there was a little police military
same thing you know so they're standing
there in their uniforms and after like
three or four songs they're like this
they took off their stuff and their
accent head banging and having a good
time so we saw the transformation of you
know a closed-down society to freedom
right before us individually in people
it was awesome yeah what does it feel
like to stand in front of 500,000 people
what is this sound like what is the
sound of their roars like pretty massive
I'm consciously you know I lost counted
lateral 307,000 but I tell you and they
don't speak your language that is such a
that's the power music man that's a land
in its own it connects people it is so
cool so yeah we went to a place that no
one spoke English or people were telling
us you know I learned English from your
lyrics
I failed English just so you know I
didn't do so well in school but wow
honey bazaar
yeah that's intense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the
Oh
in consultation
Oh
yeah
and
Oh
may be nice to watch you watching I made
this movie because things to gain
athlete to so there's a famous Oscar
that do hope you profound max check out
the link in the description you can go
and cap you're both absolutely know
which clips resonated and most of you
what lesson you going to teach this
video and immediately apply to you in
life or to business somehow leave it in
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out what you have to say I also
want to give a quick shout out to the
lonely book in the air thank you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word and posted the review on your
YouTube channel I really really
appreciate your support and I'm so glad
that you enjoy playing in this video
I'll be talking about the book your one
word by Evan Carmichael thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you
hope you teach to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
[Music]
me and a buddy growing up in school
John's an or was his name we would we
would try and top each other you know
every day like hey look what I learned
and all the liquid I got like all eight
now go back and learn something else and
then he got so the great you know high
school competition you know got us to
another level which was great and then
at some point it was like wow you know
the guys I'm playing with I need to play
with better players and I was writing I
wanted to I wrote some songs they didn't
like him they just wanted to play covers
and then I kind of decided well I've got
to start playing with other people so
right then I kind of knew that I was on
a quest I wanted to get better and some
friends didn't understand that they just
you know why don't you you know stand
with us and I was on a quest to go go
places I think it was my sophomore year
I went back to high school the summer
time to gear up start playing football
again and I had long hair at that point
and the coach said you have to get a
haircut and I said yeah but Eddie Van
Halen's got long hair and Michael
Schenker's got long hair I want to play
football and have long hair you can't do
it so right then it was one of those
Forks in the road that was pretty
pivotal in my life that I had no clue
about and I kind of just said well you
know screw this do I want to be second
strings you know playing football or I
want to be up on stage you know with a
mission you know speaking through music
I didn't know what at the time but it
was pretty much the right choice